hard work's a thing of the past in Joe
Biden's America under Democrats we've
turned into a bunch of lazy entitled
snot-nosed brats except for me of course
Americans are now working fewer hours
than before the pandemic thanks to a
shift in attitudes towards work with
more people reevaluating their work-life
balance our next generation of great
Americans are embracing things like bare
minimum Mondays where people just ease
into the work week by prioritizing
self-care over productivity
they're also quiet quitting where they
just do enough to get by call me crazy
but it seems like this is the workforce
you'd expect after years of liberal
leaders brainwashing people into
thinking they deserve everything without
lifting a finger
it's simply not fair if you can make a
million or 100 million bucks go at it
pay your fair share we deserve to be
able to retire with dignity and not
bankruptcy we can't Overlook the role
that concentrated corporate power has
played in creating the conditions for
price gouging the American people know
that we are being ripped off
the poor work ethic showing up in gen Z
it's forcing bosses all across the
country to hire seniors instead of
workers fresh out of school companies
are now recruiting older Americans on
the premise that age equals a better
employee the phone has to be in their
hand they have to consistently look at
it I'm trying to get them to engage
customers and you know just be
personable so I I think the older
population because cell phones are of a
newer thing it just they never were
brought up with it and you know it's
refreshing they start at nine they get
here at eight at ten two they leave at
five and if the store is busy they'll
put the extra time in without having to
ask it is something that I really wish I
explored years ago
okay Dan I had never heard of what do
they call Mondays he's into work Mondays
bare minimum Mondays what's wrong with a
little self-care on a Monday I love
Mondays you get going I love to wake up
in the morning get going but that's me
I'm weird you're old Dana yeah I'm old
that is that's true so I just in Reading
I read the statistics I I read all the
Articles and I still feel like maybe
this is not I feel like it's overblown
so I reached out to several of my
friends who are now working in different
Industries and they're managing younger
people and hiring younger people and
they said that before the pandemic and
after the pandemic the only thing that
has changed a little bit on this front
is you have work from home and that that
has become a real challenge because it
is hard to Mentor or to make sure that
people are getting the types of
opportunities that they might have
gotten before that whole phenomenon they
said that sometimes you'll have great
workers and sometimes you don't the
social media issue is one that they said
they're just gonna have to live with
because it's it's not going away the
other thing I believe that this younger
generation is looking at which is the
government and they want the government
to do more for them if they want to be
they want that Cradle to grave sort of
socialism that they have in Europe which
if you look at the cost look what's
happening in France right now you try to
ask people to work from to go from 62 to
64 in terms of the retirement age and
they absolutely freak out so I do think
that this is a little overblown uh
however I am encouraged that there are
people who are older that if they want
to work if they can get hired I think
that's great because they were some of
the first to lose their jobs during
covid when a lot of companies use that
as a reason to downsize they lost their
jobs and many of them were not ready for
retirement yet and they are digging into
their savings having to talk having to
maybe move in with family they didn't
want to do that so hire anybody you can
that does a lot of hard work are we
becoming friends France Judge Jeanine I
hope not I can't imagine Americans
objecting and burning places down
because they're asked to hold off
retirement to the 64 from 62. I mean
it's really ridiculous but uh I think we
are becoming more like other countries I
think it's starting to level off a
little bit you know the whole idea of
you know Generation Z uh you know being
the laziest of all and that's what what
is it 19 to 29 or something like that
the young ones I mean there are always
exceptions to that there are always
people who are going to be
self-motivated self-initiated who make a
lot of money and who just you know are
people who want to work and and succeed
one of the most important uh stats that
I saw in this whole thing was that covet
changed a lot people couldn't say it
hasn't but covet has changed a lot and
for Workaholics we I include myself in
that are working three hours less in
terms of you know a significant again a
difference in terms of hours High
earners have decreased their hours by
one and a half hours so there's like
this trend I mean it's not a movement
but it's kind of a trend and I think
that as with most things you know people
are starting to find a life work balance
but I don't want to hear that you want
to work from home because the last
person I spoke to who was working from
home was at the gym oh I signed down
this morning but I'm at the gym I mean
that's a bunch of hogwash and I also I
found it very objectionable the way some
of these hearings were conducted and you
have uh Bernie Sanders and everyone
trashing billionaires and I found it
very I thought significant quote from
um what's his name who owns yeah Howard
Schultz's own Starbucks he says the
moniker of billionaire let's just get to
that okay I grew up in federally
subsidized housing my parents never
owned a home I came from nothing I
thought my entire life was based on the
achievement of the American dream yes I
have billions now but I earned it no one
gave it to me and I share it constantly
with the people of Starbucks I mean stop
trashing these billionaires and somehow
they didn't work for what they got no
one gave it to you Heraldo you had to go
out and take it true I I did I did take
it but you know as I get older Jesse
it's interesting now that I approach my
80th year I just think that you only
live once and I wonder if uh you know I
I did too much too many little silly
little worky things that I could have
relaxed I could have been on the boat I
could have been doing something what do
you mean
you know I I think that the thing about
Jen said let's just take the kids for a
second uh yesterday you recall we were
talking about the most important most
consequential election of uh 2023 uh the
Supreme Court in Wisconsin that election
was turned by the kids voted kids coming
out voting organizing so I think that
Dana's right it is over blown this whole
notion that oh these kids they can't uh
they can't figure out life they uh
they're lazy you know they're going to
get left behind uh but you know I I'm
the kids recognizing that there's more
to life than work I think that that
maybe we have something to learn from
them Greg has a very beautiful work-life
balance that is
true I say that sarcastically all you do
is work that is true that is true what
else what else is there I I
love young people and I'm against
generalities I think there are all kinds
of people I've had the hardest working
young people and I've also have slouches
so there's more than one variable of age
we just have this tendency of one
generation looking at this is what's
hilarious right you always have one
older generation that has to look at
another one and say ah they're different
they're going to hell no well if they're
going to hell then it's your fault
Boomers right I blame the Boomers
because they're the ones that trashed
any kind of traditional life right
whether it was marriage whether it was
religion going to church whether it was
having a family and then all of a sudden
you realize you have nothing to replace
it with so what do you do you replace it
with identity right and where does
identity bring you in some kind of
tribal Warfare where you're miserable
all the time then you have the shutdown
covid which accelerates everything that
was going to happen anyway including
your expiration date if you were going
to die in 2027 you died in 2022. that's
that's what kovi did covet also caused a
spike in drug addiction that's worse
than this you should see the Obesity
epidemic among kids every video of kids
fighting they're fat I mean they're huge
it's scary how big they are kids are
just plain huge you have spikes in crime
suicide spectacle shootings tribalism
social media inspired contagions that
turn a confused young girl into a female
killer they're loaded up with drugs and
hormones it's a weird life and what's
missing what's missing meaning purpose
and connection you wonder why people
can't sleep at night it's because
they're not doing anything worthwhile in
the day and it drives them crazy you
used to be able to go to sleep because
you were exhausted now you go you can't
sleep because you're thinking about what
am I doing so I think that I had nothing
really important to say except that I
think it's bigger than a few hours of
not working I think it's a larger issue
it's a larger issue about me meaning in
life it is why Jordan Peterson is so
popular among young men right it's why
so many women are miserable it's why
women aren't happy with guys and why
guys don't hang around with women it's
why pornography is so huge all of this
stuff is coming because of a loss of
meaning and not like you said not being
able to actually deal with people what
about the 60s though weren't that the
60s four but I but if you you read
history uh the it was a time of complete
rejection of uh Traditional Values
experimentation total self-involvement
uh you know and the world was going to
hell in a hand basket and guess what the
world recovered and I think the same
thing's going to happen now I think
social media has done a lot a lot
negative and positive all right Geraldo
defends the Boomers way to go Geraldo
I'm a pre-boomer all right pre-boomer
good
is that the guy you bring over to the
house to tweeze
Elmer not everybody has an in-house
Barber coming out just for a mustache
seriously it brings the hedge clippers
very labor intensive I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now